hi my name is juana domitrescu i come
from romania
currently i'm working in the european
commission in the department working on
education culture youth and sports i
work in the higher education unit where
we are working on the implementation and
development of the erasmus plus program
i think the role of
exchange programs of mobility programs
such as erasmus plus or european
solidarity core
is
not to promote
one set of european identity values
for young people
i think the whole idea is that it
offers people the chance
to have a hands-on experience in a
different society in a different
community to be of service in that
particular community so
you see that a new thing in its own has
been kind of established by new
generations going into this program and
defining what
european values mean to them
i think it was exactly my experience as
an international student
and the fact that i was studying and
researching european identity and i was
volunteering in an organization where
people identify themselves as european a
lot
that made me want to continue this in my
professional
trajectory
so what i found is that there's two ways
of looking at european identity so of
course there's this traditional way of
understanding european identity which
stems a lot from kind of philosophical
thought and political thought of the
ages on the idea of building a europe
based on freedom so this notion actually
stems from immanuel kant as well from
the 18th century but of course it it was
even more poignant um
in light of the sec the the two world
wars and the way this really impacted
europe in devastated europe so it was
initially a political project of coming
together and establishing some european
values that we all believe in and some
goals that we can achieve together the
idea that based on freedom democracy
um
and peace we can work together to build
more than if we are at war with one
another
so as you can see this is all it really
sounds a bit top down right because this
is kind of a political approach that has
a lot of value but that doesn't
necessarily
come from the culture or or for kind of
from from society as as such from a
bottom-up approach
so that was the main challenge actually
that is the main challenge when you talk
about european identity because with
years of freedom
you have people kind of taking ownership
of
being european because they live in this
free society and they are willing and
able to try to travel and experience
different countries
so this is more constructivist approach
which looks more at
how people or european citizens
themselves identify themselves with
europe or with european values
and what do they consider to be european
or not european
what happens with short-term exchanges
such as erasmus plus or european
solidarity core
is that
it first puts people in contact with a
different culture with a different
language and it gets them to experience
a different place
in a very different way from when you're
just going on holiday because you really
have to immerse yourself in the new
society you have to come across
different ideas different ways of doing
things and that really
forces you to kind of react and change
yourself in the process which is where
the notion of european identity comes in
it ultimately equips
especially young people with skills and
views that they can employ in their
host their home society
which has this effect of
internationalization at home
meaning that you know
you're not only the one who are changed
but you can go on and change and bring
these new ideas in your home society as
well